hallöchen männer lieben freunde daher am
21.12 also morgen die welt untergehen
wird habe ich mir gedacht ich mach ein
kleines abschluss video hierzu meinem
kanal da der kanal dann in die luft
fliegen wird zusammen mit komplett
youtube komplett amerika und den ganzen
anderen leuten die dort leben wir werden
dann alle zu dies weltall fliegen unsere
ganze körperteile und das wird dann
alles ein ganz ganz toller anblick sein
davon wird bestimmt auch fotos im
internet dann auftaucht geht ja gar
nicht weil das ist ja dann alles so in
der luft geflogen
das gibt's ja dann alles nicht mehr und
nein quatsch also ich will hier gar
nicht
die moralapostel spielen die
moralapostel der die moralapostel genau
das richtig und zwar haben die man ja
eigentlich nie gesagt dass die welt
untergeht sondern den roters nur in den
mund gelegt und es fragen auch mal ganz
viele leute wie könnte die welt denn
eigentlich untergehen und da gibt es
aber links allerdings sehr sehr viele
theorien also es gibt da nicht jetzt
irgendwie dass die welt von innen
explodiert das kann natürlich auch
irgendwann passieren aber da dauert das
noch ein ganz klein bisschen vielleicht
zehn milliarden jahre oder so aber die
theorien sind eigentlich dass es
entweder eine ganz ganz große flut geben
wird aufgrund von erdbeben eine
verschiebung der polkappen was ich
eigentlich auch ganz interessant finde
weil dadurch das gleichgewicht der erde
gestört wird
wenn ihr wisst was ich meine es gibt
auch eine rückkehr des planeten biro
bevor nicht erst gerade bei einer
website gelesen habe dass es überhaupt
passieren könnte und was es ein planet
der von astronomen verschwiegen wurde
beziehungsweise nur wichtigen
staatsmännern den häuptern der welt wie
zum beispiel obama oder ich doch putins
auch gesagt der cl und sowas
die haben das halte ich der
öffentlichkeit präsentiert da sie keine
panik auslösen wollten
und wenn der in die nähe der erde kommt
werden wir ihnen die so weggezogen
aufgrund des magnetfeldes und dann gerät
alles durcheinander und die schwerkraft
geht durcheinander alles mögliche oder
es passiert einfach eine transformation
und ein anderen bewusstseinszustand also
das wäre so das simpelste ganz ganz
simpel
nee also ich wollte euch das mal ganz
gut sagen weil ich kriege wirklich viele
nachrichten mit dem betreff
weltuntergang das selber quatschen soll
und ich habe schon zwei oder dreimal
gemacht und er keine ahnung ich mach das
und keiner zu also ich denke nicht dass
die welt untergeht hier habt ihr es
und ich wollte mich trotzdem bei euch
bedanken dafür dass ihr mich dieses jahr
so gut unterstützt habt und bleib ich
könnte jetzt sagen wie geil ich finde
und ein großes herz an euch alle aber so
ein wenig nicht und deswegen wollte ich
mich einfach mal so bei euch bedanken
dafür dass ihr mich unterstützt habt ich
hoffe das geht so weiter et cetera et
cetera pp
ihr wisst was ich meine ich wollte nur
schon mal ankündigen dass am 24.12 als
wir da nicht schon alle tot sind
am 24.12 ist richtig weihnachten und was
dann noch ist das viel wichtiger als
weihnachten ist das meine website online
geht also von crafter punkt.de und ich
denke mal das wird alles ganz gut
klappen die webseite so gut wie fertig
aber es ist er als sehr immer eigentlich
so dass man drei tage oder fünf tage vor
ende
linsler los geht noch mal alles
umkrempeln zum beispiel wir sind heute
wieder ganz viele ideen gekommen die ich
dann versucht haben die art
einzuarbeiten mit dem typen mit dem ich
das machen mit dem dominik und ja also
die webseite denke ich ganz cool werden
erwartet als kein mega comeback eines
projekts zelten und webseiten und was
ich auch sagen wollte am ersten januar
höchstwahrscheinlich wird auch ein sehr
geiles video kommen und was ist das
video was ich bisher so am größten
produziert habe weil es mich auch am
längsten arbeit gekostet hat das alles
zu planen
wenn man das video sieht sieht man das
zwar nicht diese planung allerdings wenn
man es nicht an also durch den kopf
gehen lässt was man dafür alles erstmal
erfüllen muss um das hinzukriegen dann
dann schon auf sag ich mal
ich hoffe euch ich hoffe dass euch das
auffällt also macht euch keine sorgen
bezüglich 21 12 da wird nichts passieren
dass witten tag sein wie jeder andere
außer vielleicht das weiß ich nicht ihr
verpennt und nicht in der schule kommt
oder atheist ja schon ferien also wie in
nordrhein westfalen da schon ferien auch
scheißegal vielleicht werdet ihr auch an
gefurzt von eurem kumpel oder irgendwie
sowas kann ja auch passieren und dadurch
entsteht dann eine verschiebung der
planeten kann ja immer mal passieren
ich meine es mir letztes auch passiert
aber dann habe ich die wieder zurück
geschoben weil bin so stark naja ich
hoffe ihr wisst dass das ja alles nur
sarkastisch gemeint ist und ich mich
darüber eigentlich sehr lustig mache was
die alle vom weltuntergang denken wie
sie jetzt alle darum helfen bei facebook
aber egal ich wollte das video einfach
mal so nutze um die information
contractor de und das projekt am ersten
januar bis 10 jahre kein projekt sondern
ein einmaliges video wenn es gut ankommt
kommen eventuell noch mehr videos davon
und ja also das wollte ich nur ganz kurz
sagen kleine lok und dann würde ich
sagen sehen wir uns beim nächsten video
wenn wir die toten